hey guys welcome back I wanted to do a
video on the difference between not
losing weight versus slow weight loss
and the reason is if a lot of times
we'll have people that will contact me
and they're saying I'm not losing weight
okay
then I find out they are losing weight
but it's just incredibly slow so there's
a huge difference between not losing any
weight at all and losing some weight
okay I mean the actions that you would
do if you weren't losing weight are
going to be completely different than
what you would do if you have slow
waitlist so let's take a look at that
you put someone on the right program and
by the way I always want to make sure
that the data that someone's giving me
is correct so sometimes if they tell me
I'm eating perfectly right and I don't
actually find out what they're eating I
could find out it's not perfect and that
has happened so many times also you
could have someone that is possibly
cheating and they're not telling you
that's a possibility
so those things you want to rule out but
the point is if they did everything
right is they're not losing weight then
you have to make a huge change okay
there's some seriously something stuck
in their body it could be with the
thyroid it could be with the adrenal
could be with a kidney and that were
just requires more data more testing I
need to dig deep and find out what is
behind that okay so that's if you're not
losing anything if you're having slow
weight loss it's like molasses you're
losing some but it's too gradual you
don't want to make a huge change all you
want to do is strengthen the successful
actions okay so that's very different
because if I make so many changes right
here all of a sudden can turn from here
to here so so we want to look at the
quality in the quantity of the food so
we look at the quality of the protein
are there doing soy protein isolates are
they doing too much protein powder is it
low-fat protein powder that actually
raises insulin or what about the quality
of the fat are they doing corn oil or or
soy oil really bad quality are they
doing low quality carbohydrates are they
doing sports drinks so they're doing
just pure sugar with fine carbohydrates
like refined breads and things like
so we look at the quality and then look
at the quantity the protein is it too
high is it between three to six ounces
what about the fats is it too low or
maybe too high sometimes they can't
they're not used to digesting all the
fat and maybe maybe the meal is so large
and a metallus is so small we have to
adjust that some people unfortunately
have such a damaged metabolism they need
to have smaller meals or less frequent
meals okay just because everything is
molasses I'll get to that in a second
so the quality and quantity of these
proteins carbohydrates and fats are
vital and then we look at the frequency
of eating now are they doing six meals a
day or right there I'm going to put them
to three meals a day because six meals a
day is a lot of insulin every time you
ease by Gainsville insulin or maybe
they're at three maybe I need to push
them down to two meals a day okay
without any like intermittent fasting in
between no anything between the nails a
lot of people are very successful with
that but there's a small group of people
that just have a very very slow
metabolism that I have to put on one
meal a day now you might say that's
starvation but it's not because they're
having a very large meal all the
nutrients but their system is so slow
that they can run efficiently or should
I say their system is so efficient they
can run on very small amounts of food
because it's such a slow machine so on
some people we have to do that and they
eventually lose weight because the mint
because the system has been damaged over
their life specially if they've been
dieting as a kid or you know ever since
like like sometimes even parents put the
kids on a diet when they're four or five
years old well that's going to really
mess up things later in life okay now
the other thing we look at if it's slow
is there other body problems the quality
of sleep is there bladder waking them up
it's a hot flashes is it sinus like
sleep apnea do they have those issues
because it's not sleeping that's going
to make it slow
I look at digestion are they constipated
do they have heartburn they have ulcers
all that is just a symptom that there is
a digestive issue
I mean I'll even put people on a good
probiotic and all of a sudden they start
losing weight
or what about their menstrual cycle the
menstrual cycle being too heavy that
indicate too much estrogen and that
right there can stop the weight loss too
much estrogen but I don't ever support
the weight loss directly with a pill or
a nutrient because that doesn't work
there's so many pills out so that people
use that say oh yeah take this
weight-loss pill that doesn't work
because the weight is always a symptom
of something else so we know most of the
way problems are related to insulin and
insulin resistance so if you support
that problem you'll be way more
successful the really the only weight
loss pill that I use is something called
insulin and glucose support which is
I'll put a link down there if you want
more information but it supports insulin
directly it lowers insulin and that
actually helps because in the presence
of insulin you're not going to lose
weight and some people even our
pre-diabetic or diabetic they lose
weight but they still have a little
insulin problem they need some support
that's when I would use some nutrition
with that okay so I just wanted to
differentiate no weight loss or slow
waves weight loss what category are you
in and things that you can do to speed
things up thanks for watching hey if
you're enjoying my videos press the
subscribe button below and I will keep
you updated on the future event thank
you so much